[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica desde
cabo Cañaveral en Florida a continuación
hablaremos de lanzamiento de la misión
artemis que ha llevado al espacio el
cohete más grande de toda la historia
además también abordaremos el impacto
que puede tener este proyecto en el
futuro donde los viajes de seres humanos
a la luna y a Marte están más cerca que
nunca en este programa también veremos
cómo los lanzamientos de la NASA desde
esta pequeña localidad del sur de
Estados Unidos suponen una gran
inyección económica para los negocios
locales ya que miles de turistas vienen
hasta aquí atraídos por misiones como la
de artemis 3
por favor
[Música]
en la madrugada del 16 de noviembre
partió la misión no tripulada de artemis
desde esta plataforma que ven a lo lejos
en el centro espacial Kennedy situada al
sur de Estados Unidos algunos
privilegiados invitados por la NASA
pudieron presenciar El despegue desde
aquí aseguran que vivieron una
experiencia inolvidable no podía creer
que al fin iba a ver salir artemis y fue
emocionante emocionante era imposible no
llorar una de las cosas más emocionantes
explican era seguir la cuenta regresiva
desde este emblemático reloj y ya cuando
la cuenta atrás de los 10 minutos ha
comenzado a todo el mundo
precipitándose para sus puestos
para poder estar en primera línea con el
lanzamiento de artemis la Nasa en
colaboración con la estación espacial
Europea y otros socios Internacionales
emprende El regreso a la luna después de
medio siglo la última vez fue en
diciembre de 1972 con Apolo 17 algunos
expertos en la materia señalan
directamente al costo económico y
político que supone este tipo de
proyectos espaciales a veces es difícil
asumir el costo político de ir a la luna
muchas veces la excusa fundamental es
Tenemos muchos problemas en la tierra
para para no ir para tener que ir a la
luna para escribir la luna con todo lo
que pero en realidad yo creo que es al
revés creo que está aprobado que la
exploración espacial no ha hecho más que
traer beneficios a la calidad de vida en
la tierra este estudioso que un día
convirtió su pasión por el espacio en su
forma de vida de fin de estas misiones
Galácticas porque asegura es la única
forma de que la sociedad avance gracias
a la tecnología no hay nada en la vida
diaria hoy por hoy que no que no tenga
un componente de tecnología espacial
desde nuestros celulares las cámaras el
GPS
medicina
muchísimo muchísimo Campos están tocados
directamente por exploración espacial y
creo que el mundo tal cual lo conocemos
no existiría si no fuera por las
promoción espacial artemis es el
proyecto más caro más potente y más
grande de toda la historia de
aeroespacial el cohete ls de 98 metros
de altura equivale un edificio de 30
plantas pesa más de 84 toneladas la
cápsula orión también tiene mayor
capacidad y esta vez irá mucho más lejos
que en los años 70 con Apolo la cápsula
orión en particular porque la cápsula va
a llevar más tripulación en este caso
cuatro astronautas que podrían llevar
hasta la luna y va a ir al espacio
profundo 40.000 millas de distancia de
la luna 280,000 millas de la tierra pero
este proyecto va mucho más allá de ir a
la Luna el objetivo final es que el
satélite acabe convirtiéndose en una
especie de estación de servicio para los
viajes que se realicen en un futuro
entre la Tierra y Marte y luego vamos a
establecer presencia continua para poder
entonces
establecer una base lunar y con esta lo
que aprendamos podamos ir entonces a
otros destinos incluyendo el planeta
Marte los lanzamientos sin cabo
Cañaveral atraen a miles de turistas de
todo el mundo y eso supone una buena
inyección económica para negocios como
este vienen de todo el mundo Cada día
desde el primer intento del lanzamiento
muchos venían y decían bueno no hemos
visto el lanzamiento aún pero al menos
nos llevamos una camiseta de recuerdo
Brenda pudo ver el lanzamiento desde su
casa apenas sin dormir ha abierto la
tienda y desde primera hora no han
dejado de llegar turistas como Este
joven mexicano que manejó desde Carolina
del Norte hasta Florida me enteré de que
iba a haber un tercer a Tanto poder
lanzar la nave de árabes 10 horas de
camino pero para algo tan emocionante
como estos 10 horas hasta nada entre
tazas camisetas y gorras espere
encontrar un buen recuerdo del día en
que artemis puso rumbo a la luna creo
que es muy importante tener algo que te
recuerde de momentos especiales
especialmente como un momento histórico
Entonces el poder tener una camisa una
playera una gorra o un artículo pequeño
que te pueda tener ese significado
grande es algo muy importante muchos
negocios y amantes del espacio ya
esperan al próximo lanzamiento de
artemis pero no será hasta al menos 2024
cuando se enviarán de nuevo seres
humanos a la luna y Se volverá a hacer
historia Cuando se envía la primera
mujer y a la primera persona de color
hasta aquí enlace Norteamérica Gracias
por sintonizarnos y recuerde que para
ver de nuevo Este programa puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]